So hey, everyone.
I'm the CEO of Timber AI.
I've previously worked on big
data and semantic
web technologies,
and I'm going to
show you today
how with Timber you can run
graph algorithms on top of
relational databases,
mostly data warehouse
and data lakes.
So let's start from the gap.
Why you cannot run
graph algorithms
today on your
data warehouse or
data lake? So the gap that we
see today is that most data is
stored in tables and is being
models and tables
and columns.
Graph databases and knowledge
graphs store
information in a graph
structure, but also
give you a way
to define type
of relationships
between your all
of your business
entities. So,
if you're here on the left and
your data is a table,
for you to run graph algorithm
to understand
what relationships
I have in the data,
you need to move and
build a knowledge
graph. Well, with timber,
we we took
an approach that was
different from
the current standards.
We said instead
of creating a new
database, let's see how we can
connect to the existing table
and columns, incorporate all
the knowledge graph
capabilities.
So timber
essentially transform
your existing databases
into a knowledge
graph.
We connect almost any database
in the market. We
build a virtual
knowledge graph.
Now in this virtual
knowledge graph,
you can declare all
of the relationships
even though there are
different schemas,
different tables,
different databases.
The process of
building the knowledge
graph is virtual,
so you don't need
to copy data.
You can do it with SQL.
So if you're already familiar
on how to create a table,
you already know how to create
a knowledge graph
with timber.
But if you prefer not
to do it in SQL,
we also can do it
user user interface.
So we offer for domain experts
or people who are
familiar with
the specific
business logic and
want to embed that
this in the knowledge
graph, they can also do it.
And with teamwork request,
we work with SQL,
any analyst,
business analyst,
any graduate that
finish a university
can easily already know how to
work with timber.
So let me show you
the the benefits
the benefits of moving from
the relational model
to a knowledge
graph.
So writing a complex
queries in
SQL has has been
a tough job up
until now. Let's
take, for example,
fraud detection.
Writing fraud
detection queries
in SQL is very
complex and hard
to write, but also
to maintain.
So here on the left,
you can see
an example of a query
without timber,
which is complex
and hard because
of all the relationship that
exists in the data
that you need
to explicitly declare.
But when you work
with timber,
you you you still
write the query
in SQL, but you do
it on the knowledge
graph. So you don't work with
table and columns.
You work with
business entities.
Each business
entity has its own
properties, its own unique
relationship that you can take
advantage, and you can write
those queries
a lot more simpler
and intuitive.
The other benefit you get,
it's not only in
the query side
but also in
the exploration side.
Imagine that you
have hundreds,
thousands of table,
and you want to
understand what
relationships I
have in my data
warehouse or in my data lake.
So Timber introduces graph
exploration over
relational database.
Even if your table
format is a table,
you can still look at all of
your data as one
virtual graph.
So you can start
with one entity,
for example, Samsung.
You can see the relationships
to Samsung Electronics,
and you can see the subsidiary
and the CEO, for example.
And each note is
based on the ontology
that defines your
business domain.
Now I said before that
for each concept,
you have
the business properties
and relationships.
So here, right on the menu,
you can see all the properties
that were declared
in the model,
but also all
the relationships.
Now each time you
explore your data,
an SQL query is run
behind the scene.
So your your data
is still stored
where it is today.
But what about
graph algorithms?
We thought we've been able to
do graph traversals in SQL.
We've introduced
even a a graph
visualization on
topic relation
database, but we thought that
a graph analytics and graph
algorithms was
missing for some
type of queries
that are impossible
to write in SQL.
For example, if I want to find
similar products,
similar customers,
build community of sessions of
a specific communities of of
product types, I can do all of
that with graph algorithms in
graph databases,
but not on my
relational model.
One of the most common things
that I want to do is
do link prediction.
Try to predict
what is the link
between two entities.
There is no operator in SQL or
there is no way to do that in
the SQL language.
This is why with Timber,
we thought to
incorporate inside
the language itself.
So what are the benefits of
graph algorithms?
First of all,
you can reach all
of your data with,
for example,
the link prediction.
You can predict
links that does
not exist today in the data.
We also introduced new query
capabilities. Now we can do in
SQL find similarity or ranking
of a specific
entity in your in
your knowledge graph.
This also allows
you to discover
and analyze patterns,
communities.
But what is the real benefit?
The real benefit of of our
approach is that no expertise
needed in graph theory.
If you already know SQL,
you know how to query tables,
you already know how to do
community pattern detection,
find similarity and
ranking in SQL.
Now let me show
you the process
of how we've done it.
So how we did it?
So Timber actually integrated
with the lead platforms that
allow you to run
graph algorithms.
The most popular is NetworkX,
which is a CPU Python library
of graph algorithms.
So if you want to
run your graph
algorithms using the the most
popular library,
Timber works with NetworkEAKS
to do the execution.
If you want accelerated graph
algorithms and leverage GPU to
get very fast results,
we also integrate
with rapid CU Graph.
Rapid CU Graph
benchmarks are very,
very fast and allow you to do
different type of
workloads that
doesn't require
you to wait for
the results of
the graph algorithm.
We also integrate with Apache
Spark to allow you
to do parallel
computation. If you
have big data,
if you have hundreds
of gigabytes,
terabytes of data,
and you need to
run global graph
algorithms, This will this is
where we can integrate with
graph frames, graphics to run
all of your graph
algorithms in
a scalable way.
Even if your data
grows in the future,
Spark will be able
to handle it.
So let me talk
talk a little bit
about the architecture.
So up until now,
Timber was connected to all of
the databases. And for a user
to run a query,
instead of connecting directly
to the database,
he connected to Timber
knowledge graph,
and we were and
we will know how
to query the tables
in each database.
But with graph algorithms,
you can actually
now the process
is different. Timber
runs the query
that is intended for the graph
algorithm, runs
the graph algorithm,
and shows back to the user.
So now the user can
get the results
of a graph algorithm directly
when he works with the timber
platform in SQL.
The way we've introduced it is
using table functions.
So imagine that each graph
algorithm is a function,
but not a standard
function in SQL.
It's it's a virtual table that
you can call as
a function because
you have,
results based on
a specific query.
And you can choose whatever
platform is suited for you.
You can choose Spark.
You can choose
RAPIDS, CU Graph,
or NetworkX when you
configure Timber.
But what is
the biggest benefit
in our approach is
that now any BI tool,
you can expose
the data enrichment
and all the insights you got
from the graph
algorithm directly
to the business side.
So you don't even
have to know SQL.
If I run a graph algorithm,
this the output,
the enrichment,
the insights that
was generated
from can be exposed
to the whole
enterprise using the standard
BI tool that you
already have.
So I talked to you
about the process
how we did it and
what libraries
we can connect to.
Let me show you a demo of how
it really works.
So we took a sample of a data
warehouse that exists
on Azure synapse,
the Azure hosted
data warehouse,
and we have information
about customers.
Let me, for example,
query the data and
show you a sample
of customers.
So we have the customer
name, last name,
gender, email address,
all the information that is
typical in a retail
company that
stores information
about customers.
We also have information
about products.
So now we can
query the product
table and get a list of all
the products. So I get from
the product ID, product name,
description. You can
get the manufacturer
, the brand name, color,
all the attributes you have of
a product.
But this what makes
this interesting
is if we want to
analyze the sales
of all of my products
and customers.
So now I can go to this online
sales table, and I can see for
each customer which product he
bought at which price,
if there was a discount,
what what date,
and all of the typical values
you have for a sale.
Now timber connected
to the data
warehouse, and we
model an ontology
on top of it.
So this is the timber platform
and we only model the concepts
that are relevant for our for
our algorithms.
In this example,
we took the sales table,
mapped it to
the sales concept.
We mapped the table
of products
to product concept
and of customer.
So we actually
created a a concept
that also represents
a customer.
Now for each one of them,
I can see all the list of
properties and all of
the relationships.
When we looked at the the data
warehouse previously,
we didn't saw the relationship
that exists between
those statements,
But this can be declared in
Timber as part of
the knowledge graph.
So I can see that Timber has
made the purchase.
So now I can go and
and see sales,
and I can see that
sales has a ratio
to a product and a customer.
And if I go to product,
I can see
the relationship onto
the sale. This is one
way to explore it.
Another one is I
can just click
on sales and say
find relationships.
And now I can see all
of the relationships
directly in my
knowledge graph.
Now once we have that and we
declared the relationships,
we mapped all of our data that
is relevant for
the algorithm,
then we can move
to the SQL lab.
The SQL lab allows you to look
at all of the concepts
in the ontology.
So let's, for example,
look at a sales concept.
So we go to
the timber schema,
and we can see
look for the sales
concept. Here we can find all
the properties of a sale,
but if I want to
look at all of
the relationships, I
can go to detimber.
Detimbers allow
allow me to look
at a denormalized
view of the same
entity. So now I
can go to sales,
and now I can explore all of
the relationships of a sale.
So I can see that a a brought
bought the same I can go to
the same product
that was bought
in in in a specific sale.
I can go to a a sale was made
by a customer,
or I can go to the product of
the of us of that
specific sale.
So all of those relationships
and any relationship with
declaring the ontology is
available for any
user who works
with SQL. And
this is the first
step before we run our
graph algorithms.
You can see all the properties
of an entity, all of
the relationships,
and now we can start building
our our graph algorithms.
So how did we expose it?
So timber introduced
a new schema
called g timber.
Now in g timber,
you can select your graph
algorithm that
you're interested.
For example, if I want to run
Louvain for the algorithm,
then I can see what
are the results
that is expected
from that table
function. So when I look at g
timber Louvain,
I can see that
the results is the ID,
could be a customer
ID, a product ID,
and in which community this ID
belongs to.
If I look at, for example,
a Jacquard similarity to find
similar people,
similar products,
I can see I have
the similarity,
which basically says,
is it similar or not?
And I have the ID,
which could be the product and
the similar one.
So we have two
entities and and
one similarity that gives you
the similarity between them.
You can also run page
rank, for example.
Timber supports any graph
algorithm that is supported by
those libraries.
So if yours if you
want a specific
library that if
it's CU Graph,
NetworkX, or Spark,
this can be exposed virtually
as part of Timber.
Now if I want to,
for example,
run a Jacquard,
let's find a similar customers
based on products
that they bought.
So I previously
saved some queries
just to show you
how it works.
So I can find
similar customers
based on Jacquard.
And now let me show
you how it works.
So we we have
the GTimber schema.
We have the Jacquard
table function.
Now the the the each algorithm
receives three parameters.
First is the ID,
the first ID.
Second, is the second ID to
build the graph.
So, basically, you have two
entities and a relationship
between them, and
you can declare
a weight a weight of
that relationship.
For in this example,
we're saying give
me a customer
ID and give me customer ID who
bought the same product.
So we're looking
about customers
who bought the same
product here,
and I want to find how much
products they've bought
that is similar.
So I I group by
and get the number
of products that is shared by
those two customers.
Now, of course, I
can run this query,
and I will just get results of
a a customer ID,
another customer ID,
and the number
of products that
they share. And I can also run
the graph algorithm
to see whether
they're similar or not.
So just to give you an example
of the results,
then you can see that this
customer bought
the same customer
as all of those.
And it changes, like,
this this this customer bought
those three customers bought
the same product and so on.
So let's run the Jacquard
algorithm and see
the results here.
See what how I can find now
similar customers based on on
a purchase on purchase
of products.
So here is the results.
We have a customer ID. ID.
First, I I have
a customer ID.
I have the similar one,
and I have the similarity
between them.
Similarity mean means that it
bought the same product.
And for each customer,
you get which
customer is similar
to him. Now there
is no way for
me to do this in SQL without
applying a Jacquard similarity
algorithm.
Now we can take
these results.
This is saved as a temp table
or as a a full
table in the data
warehouse, and now we can
incorporate as part
of the ontology.
So we actually went and and
mapped one of those tables to
the customer concept and added
this as a relationship.
So now I have a a relationship
for a customer to
a customer and,
basically, with a similar
customer name.
So how is this
exposed to users?
Let me show you.
I'll go back to
the saved queries,
and now I can run
give me similar
customers of Adam.
For example, I'm interested in
a specific customer ID.
And now because I introduced
this as a relationship
in the ontology,
when I look at the metadata of
a customer,
I can see all
the properties but
also the relationship.
So now I have a relationship
called similar customer that
this is the output
of the jacquard
similarity algorithm.
So let's run this
query just to
show you the results.
So here, now for Adam,
I can see look.
Those customers are
similar to him.
So if they bought
a product that
Adam did in Bath,
then you should
recommend the product
that they bought to Adam.
You can actually build
a recommendation
system now based
on those results.
Now let me show
you a different
algorithm. If you,
for for example,
want to find community
of customers,
for example,
based on a a a of customer
behavior or purchase
frequency,
we can now use the Duveen
algorithm to
detect communities
of customers.
Now this is very similar to
the Jacquard one.
The only difference
is the name
of the algorithm
we want to run.
So here we are
running the Louvain
and we can find for all of my
customers which
community they are.
So let's run this query.
So in this example,
we're using a NetworkX,
but you can configure either
other one of
the other platform.
So here for each customer,
the ID now represents
a customer.
I see in which community
he belongs to.
Now this is also
something that
now I can now
integrate as part
of the ontology.
So when I go back
to the ontology,
you can see we already created
a customer community concept,
mapped the communities to it,
and created
a relationship between
customer and
customer community.
So for each customer here,
now I can find
similar customers
or find community of con of
customers and start
analyzing them.
Let's see, for example,
a query that leveraged this.
So I'll go back to
the saved query,
and I'll query
all the customer
communities based
on the relationship
we introduced in
the ontology.
So here, what are
we interested in?
So we start by
the customer ID.
We get the label,
which represent the name of
the customer,
and we have the we also want
the gender and in
which community
this specific customer is.
And we also query
the the the timber
customer concept,
and we want only
customers that
were identified in
a specific community.
So here I got the results.
I got the customer
ID, customer name,
the gender, and
the community ID.
Now all of this, what
it actually does,
it leverages
the table that was
created from the output.
I can see what Timber actually
sends to the data warehouse in
order to identify
which customer
in which community he is.
So as you can see,
here we are doing
join in order
to understand for
each customer
in which community he is.
So if you look at the tables,
if you this is
stored in a graph
algorithms output schema.
This is where timber
stores the results.
Now let's visualize it.
Let's see how we can take this
one step further.
So here I got the results.
I want to visualize them so I
can go to the explore button.
And now we can visualize
all of my data.
I see the customer
ID, name, gender,
and community. Let's change
the visualization.
Let's do, for example,
a a bar chart.
Let's count all the customers
in each community.
Let's run the query.
So, I did by customer ID by
community ID. Sorry. Yes.
So here I get count
by community ID.
Yeah.
So here I added I
have the community
number. So I have I have ten
communities, and I can see for
each one of them
how many people
are in it. We can even break
this further by saying,
look at the gender
of each people
in each community.
So now we can see this is this
is actually quite close,
but in this community there is
almost double male
than female.
We can also visualize
it differently.
If I want to stack them,
then I can stack the bars so I
can easily understand how many
of them are female
and how many
of them are males.
So this is quite interesting.
In the seven community,
there are more
males than female,
almost double,
but in the twelfth community,
you can see it's
it's the opposite.
This allows you to understand
better what are
the relationship,
how to classify,
how to understand
the relationship
that exists in your data by
introducing graph algorithms.
This is available not only to
the technical people,
to data scientists,
but to the whole enterprise.
So, I'm interested in,
the aspects related
to the schema
management where,
when you build
the knowledge graph,
integrating
different, tables,
as you you you do
in in your system,
how do you manage
the ontology,
like, the common schema over
your knowledge
graph where when
these all these
tables might have,
you know, different
overlapping,
schemas, that, you know,
might be heterogeneous by
different names for
the same source,
different ways of
structuring data.
how do you handle that?
So in timber,
once you introduce
the ontology, you can map
different sources to it.
And in the mapping process,
you can leverage SQL to do to
clean the data, to
transform the data.
So if I have two
tables, for example,
that represents a customer,
and with one, I have
a customer name,
and in the other one,
I have a column called name,
In the mapping step,
you can transform the name of
the column and give
it a different
alias to match it
into a standardized
meaning to the whole
enterprise.
And this is also true
for relationships.
Timber supports one to many,
many to many relationships,
and you can declare
the semantic
name of each of
those relationship
in the knowledge graph. Okay.
So you're using SQL
as the transformation
and mapping language.
That's that sounds great.
and then another
related question
is now how do you
manage identity?
How do my how how
do you manage
record linkage,
when you have,
different entities
that represent
the same person, for example,
in different tables?
How how do you do you manage
the the construction
there of of that,
aggregated entity?
So, one of the benefits
of working
with SQL and Data
Warehouse and
Data Lakes, they're
they're well
suited for aggregations.
So if you want to
do aggregations
on top of
the ontology and want
want to aggregate
different sources,
they are actually optimized to
do to do it. Okay.
So that that is happening,
on on the the data
warehouse or
the data lake. Yeah.
Upstream from,
the import in in timber.
Exactly. So in timber,
it's just a virtual
knowledge graph.
You have all
the definitions in
the ontology, all
the definitions
of the mappings.
And what we do,
we just introduce an a virtual
SQL schema that you can query
like it's just another scheme
in your data warehouse.
So you don't need to see all
the table and columns.
You can see the ontology and
work with that and
as an obstruction
layer. And I I might
I've missed it.
the ontology, how
how is it defined?
How how this how do you expect
the user to define it?
So I think it's it's best if
I'll show you an example.
Maybe that that
will also time.
Be better for for everyone.
So let me share my screen.
So in Timber, you
can define for
let's take, for example,
the the customer concept.
So in Timber, you can visually
add more properties.
You can see all the properties
in the ontology,
or you can create new ones.
You can create
the relationships
directly in the user
interface.
So it can introduce a new
relationship in the ontology.
You can give it the name,
the inverse name,
the target concept,
the properties on which this
relationship is built
on, and so on.
This is one way you can model
the whole ontology
and timber.
And you, of course,
you have the inheritance that
allows you to do
the subclassing
of concepts.
Another option to do it is in
using SQL statements.
So here we can see,
the create statement
of a concept
in the ontology.
So if you're familiar
with the create
table, this is
just an extension
of the create
table that instead
of table you use
concept and we
introduce the inherits as part
of the SQL language.
So you can define hierarchies
and do the subclass
in timber.
Okay. Thank you.
So, ontologies are
also represented
in SQL.
And do you allow allow the,
the possibility to import
ontologies from
OWW, for example,
like standard schemas,
taxonomies,
from, from the web? Yes.
So Timber is is
fully compatible
with OWL. We
implemented Timber
based on all
the inference rules
that exist in OWL
so we can take
existing ontologies
like DBpedia,
like fiber ontology,
the financial ontology,
and load them into Timber and
make these make them available
to SQL readers
as well. Great.
Olivier is asking,
how do you call
external functions,
in Timber AI?
So those are not
external function.
Those are table function.
So the function is
exposed as a table,
as a virtual table,
that you call it
as a function.
This is something that is part
of the SQL standard.
Some SQL databases also have
table functions.
But what we've done here,
we took the algorithms
and made
them available as
table functions.
So the integration
part between
the relational and the graph
algorithm library is based on
those virtual
table functions.
Okay. No. It it
doesn't have to
be in the underlying DB.
So I saw the Oliver
also asked,
do you need the feature
in the underlying
database? So, no,
you you have you can
have the feature
exists in network
x, in CU Graph,
or in Apache Spark.
This is where
the actual algorithm
is being run-in memory in a in
those in one of those specific
platforms.
Great.
Oh, we actually
just got a question
from, Jakub, who's asking,
if you consider a virtual KG
being a stopgap,
before moving to a Graph DB,
or is there something inherent
in SQL first virtual KGs,
that will be
necessary for some
time to come? So,
when you talk about moving to
a Graph DB, you're actually
talking about
full materialization
of your data to
a new database.
So you take data from the data
or some data lake,
and you do it here,
and you materialize
in a new graph DB.
Well, Timber also supports
materialization. So
Timber is virtual.
You start with
a virtual knowledge
graph, but for
specific workloads,
specific complex queries,
you can materialize
it in the in
in memory or inside the data
warehouse or data lake,
so we get better performance.
So we don't see it
as the first step.
We see it as
a complete different
approach that doesn't require
you to go full
materialized from
day one. You can
still materialize
for better performance,
and you can still do
graph traversals,
graph algorithms,
and there is no
need to to move
all of your data from day one
to a graphDB.
There are scenarios
like a transactional use cases
that you need that
Graph DBs are
well suited to handle.
And timber is mostly
used for analytics,
for the analytics
part. Great.